surion curds here in Qamishli
northeastern syria are angry in december
donald trump surprised everyone by
announcing that the US would pull out of
syria and quickly that could leave the
kurds vulnerable to attacks from turkey
which sees some of them as terrorists
the Kurds have been fighting tooth and
nail against Islamic state alongside US
troops it's been a costly fight the
Kurds fear being abandoned by a u.s.
withdrawal and so too do many of the
us's allies in the region enter John
Bolton US National Security Advisor he's
jetting around the Middle East
clarifying confusion putting out the
fire that Trump started his message the
US isn't simply packing up and leaving
in December Trump told the Pentagon to
prepare to leave Syria within a hundred
days now he's changed his mind
I never said we're doing it that quickly
I'm balton recently in Israel also says
that withdrawal is conditional we're
gonna be discussing the president's
decision to withdraw but to do so from
northeast Syria in a way that makes sure
that Isis is defeated and is not able to
revive itself
he's now in ankara to assure turkey that
the u.s. will leave but bit by bit
that chimes with red chip type arrow on
Turkey's president Turkey sees itself as
the dominant regional power writing in
The New York Times this week he said he
agreed that the US should withdraw but
slowly US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
is also currently touring the Middle
East he has raised concerns that Turkey
might try and attack the Syrian Kurds
Pompeo said a Dewan had made a
commitment to President Trump that
forces who fought with US troops against
Islamic state would be protected Bolton
will also press for a pledge from Ankara
that it will not attack Kurdish fighters
in Syria as a condition for a US troop
withdrawal before Turkey which has a
long-standing and bloody feud with the
Kurds the
we'll be hard to swallow okay let's find
out where this is heading with DW story
and Jones joining us from Istanbul
Dorian how likely is it that Bolton will
be getting the assurances he wants that
Ankara will not be launching a major
offensive against the Kurds in Syria
after American troops leave that country
well it's gonna be very difficult for
John Bolton already Ankara is pushed
back very hard against these calls for
assurances for this Syrian Kurdish
militia Ankara says they are a terrorist
organization linked to an insurgency
inside Turkey and they are within their
rights to attack this group on top of
that Bolton does seem to have limited
leverage punker is quite happy to wait
for the us's
unconditional withdrawal that they say
president Trump has said they are
pulling out and he'll be pulling out
quickly on top of that Bolton's new
conditions for withdrawal doesn't seem
to be we have been supported by other
colleagues there Mike Pompeo a Secretary
of State appears to be taking a more
harder stance and interpreting Trump's
words and saying that there appears to
be no conditions and this is the fact
that all this lack of clarity means that
Ankara is looking to one person that is
president Trump and president earthworm
will be looking for some conversational
meeting with Trump to hammer out the
final arrangements and that means that
Rama Bolton really has little
opportunity of extracting any
concessions from Ankara okay with the
military vacuum ahead there's a
political vacuum emerging as well and
there's been speculation that a Syria
could be seeing a de facto partitioning
is that where all of this is headed
well that has certainly been a concern
and in fact anchor on Damascus have won
the few areas of common ground they both
say they are committed to the
maintaining the territorial integrity of
Syria and that's why there's a great
deal of concern over the u.s. is backing
of this Syrian Kurdish militia which
controls nearly a quarter of the country
now that support appears to be ending
the hope fears of our breaking up of
Syria does seem to be removed
having said that turkey does have a
large military footprint in Syria if it
was to extend that territorial control
against the Syrian Kurdish militia that
would make Turkey a major player given
and the threat of a further petition of
Syria given it is a major supporter of
Syrian rebel or position ok briefly if
you could whatwhat about Islamic state
does turkey have the military capability
and the political will to fight Islamic
state in Syria well it certainly is a
big question and that will be a question
being raised in Washington now Ankara
has said it is committed to fighting
Islamic state but what we understand
behind the scenes is that Ankara saying
if you want us to take up this fight
then we need military support from the
United States and that could mean that
the United States has to commit even
more forces and it presently has in
Syria to support any Turkish military
operation against the Islamic state
the question is would Washington be
prepared to do that that would be a
major step back for Trump and I think
some people are also suggesting that
these calls for major military support
is giving hunker our way out of not
fighting the Islamic state
Dorian thank you very much for that from
Istanbul today